Nora is with us in Maryland hi Nora
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Oh Dave
how Anthony it's so nice to talk to you
today you too what's up well we did FPU
although part of it got cut because of
the quarantine and so we're but we're
continuing on we're paying the debt
we've just about to pay off for student
loans and we have to debt left one is
HELOC to use Chris Hogan's term and the
other is a car note now the key lock is
around 33 then the car note is around
between 27 28 and logically you would
think you just go with car note for that
next but the car note has a fixed
interest and the he lock has a variable
interest so it's the payments for that
have been all over the scale anywhere
about sixty dollars difference here and
there how much how much debt have you
paid off so far oh not much our gazelle
is a little lame right now but we were
not get critical to start with our
biggest bleed $27,000 car no that's debt
critical yeah well we weren't bankrupt
but you were well over into the land of
stupid
Wow now for 27 it's the only car note no
that's still in the land of stupid well
if you say okay okay I mean that's just
nuts I mean what do you guys make oh
between 140 and 150 so why have you not
paid off of that because we're working
on it
mama we're we're doing it no that's true
like I said our gazelle is a little bit
lame but we're we're healing her wounds
and we're we're gonna kick her in she's
going to start running faster okay
because it affects the answer yeah
because how long you're gonna if you're
gonna limp along and stay in debt for
eight years I can't really help you much
well now if you're gonna get with it and
pay this off in one year what you should
do
then the answer it doesn't matter which
one you pay first because one hair one
years not gonna matter and you should do
that making a hundred and forty thousand
and paying off fifty grand
nor I'm curious so you said your gazelle
is kind of lazy right now why is it lazy
what are you doing are you enjoying the
money or no not lazy not lazy but lame
why a lot of this has to do with
emotional concepts of money you know
we're working it along the biggest thing
was getting that being able to stay
within the budget of what we made per
month and that's the other thing which
is I don't know if you run into this and
I hope you don't pay your people like
this day but maybe you do do you pay
them every two weeks or twice a month my
business I'm just asking first and fifth
placement first insisted okay if it's
every two weeks each month you don't get
a set amount of money yeah but like you
but twice you do get a set amount of
money you get a couple of months you get
a little bit more money that's it so you
said well we're trying to do is to live
off the two paychecks so that the twice
a month
excuse me twice a year when we get to
the extra paycheck we're trying to use
that to put down that as well okay how
old are you me I'm 55 okay and you guys
have been married 25 30 years right no
we've been married would be 20 years
though yeah all right so um sometimes
Nora people have to get in pain before
they're willing to change other times
you can just decide with the power of
your intellect and act of your will to
be willing to change only after that
willingness to change occurs at your
home will this matter okay cuz the plan
your own right now sucks I'm struggling
to live on 150 thousand dollars and
emotionally trying to get it to where
listen if I told you in order to save
the life of your husband that you had to
be debt-free in 12 months you wouldn't
be giving me talks about being paid over
two weeks you'd be on a freaking budget
beans
nice rice and beans you would rolled up
your sleeves and done this because it
mattered but it doesn't matter yet and
when it starts mattering then you're
gonna pay both of these off so quickly
because you make enough money to pay off
the $60,000 in debt I said fifty was 27
and 33 you make enough to pay it off in
one year yeah and then all of the you
know the gyrations of the payments the
two magic weeks a year where you get
three checks instead of two checks none
of that matters anymore and so really
the truth is Noor we can't really help
you until you decide you're going to get
more serious about this because I'm not
trying to be mean to your smart aleck
with you I was a minute ago but I'm done
with that part of it now that it's just
a cold
honest truth it's your doctor looking at
you and saying you're gonna die of a
heart attack or you're gonna lose 50
pounds but I can't make you lose the 50
pounds I can't make you want to lose the
50 pounds I just can give you the
information and then you decide if
you're gonna lose the 50 pounds and
that's where we are we can't but but
you've got more excuses than Congress
has in Congress has and so you know
you're gonna have to get the point that
none of that matters that all that
matters is I'm willing to do what it
takes to change my life you have to have
that I've had it moment and you haven't
yet and so all I can do is encourage you
to find that moment and that's when
things will change for you guys and all
the math will start working it's it's
amazing because you make a lot of money
you know a David this goes back to one
of the questions that questions the one
that comments are always hear from
people is you know what if I made a lot
more money I wouldn't be in debt if I
had more I wouldn't be where I am today
you know the Ramsey stuff is not for
poor people right same thing the same
thing you know and and this call just
just just put some fire up beneath me
and I hope America here says I'm making
140 thousand but I still am struck me
I'm still emotionally to live on the
budget
I live on them and so this this is why
people live paycheck to paycheck some of
it is because their income is over some
of it the majority of it is because you
just don't want to do what you have to
do to get ahead of the game yeah it's so
and and the thing is you've been okay
for so long yes I've been married 20
years you'd never had a crisis you're 55
you've never had a crisis and you've
been okay and really the enemy of the
excellent the enemy of the best is not
the worst
it's the okay the way the Frog gets
boiled is you turn it up a little bit at
a time
yep Tory didn't even realize it's
getting hotter and hotter and hotter and
you get boiled and then you say things
like well we only owe $27,000 on her car
yeah man I'd be freaking out that's what
she other but she bought it for more I
know but I'd be freaking out we don't
have a debt problem you do you know and
that's what we're doing so you're
getting boiled for oh yeah you know
that's what and it's just the enemy of
the best is not the worst it's the
mediocre it's the okay I'm okay I'm okay
why do I need to do this and you won't
ever do it this is the Dave Ramsey show